[Music]
a choice it's based on a Nicholas Sparks
novel they did the notebook and did you
like when the notebook came out I know a
lot of women really like that movie yeah
that was that was an unhealthy obsession
for me going on with the notebook I saw
it when I was 18 and I remember falling
in love and with Noah and Allie and I
actually had that Christmas that it came
out my mom got me the notebook
stationery set so I would write love
letters with like Rachel McAdams and
Ryan Gosling down the bottom so I was
like that was a true commitment stuff
yeah you really have you did you ever
you know like I've had I've had some
women say to me if a guy doesn't like
that movie I can't go out with him oh
yeah I've done that I used to make
boyfriends I mean literally I in fact I
had a boyfriend Russell Brand who I made
watch the notebook just to see what his
emotional reaction would be to the movie
I mean I feel like I tested my
boyfriends by making them watch it right
so if he was just laughing good that was
crappy bad this isn't a good fit yeah